il y a deux jours une équipe d'Assaut a
tué le président du Nigéria monsieur
Oudot
[Musique]
pourtant vous ne pouvez pas prouver que
nous ne sommes pas impliqués ça ne vous
inquiète pas non monsieur ça me terrifie
vous devez prendre les choses en main
entendu qu'est-ce que tu vas leur dire
la corruption remonte bien plus haut que
la CIA salut les frères il rejoint
l'équipe j'ai pensé que son ex sera la
bienvenue souhaite-moi bonne chance
bonne chance et c'est mauvais ça a fait
tout ce que tu trouveras sur ce Domingo
de
chavezia avec le plus beau tableau de
chasse je dois savoir qui est derrière
tout ça vous êtes le seul à pouvoir me
renseigner c'est vous ou rien
vous avez vu vous me faites rougir
vous savez quel est le risque une
convergence la fusion d'un cartel de la
drogue et d'une organisation terroriste
il transporterait ce qu'ils veulent des
humains des armes ou encore des
kamikazes des ressources inépuisables
combinées à une haine sans limite
il n'en sera rien sous ma gouvernance
le monde est un jeu de chaise musicale
permanent
on est cerné par des vipères et des
traîtres
ou Jacques loin d'imaginer à qui vous
avez affaire
je parie que je le saurai bientôt
[Musique]
Jack est en train de risquer sa vie j'ai
toujours voulu être un fédéral la CIA
c'était le deuxième choix le quatrième
tu veux vraiment savoir
qu'est-ce qu'il a dit il m'a raccroché
au nez oh comme d'hab
[Applaudissements]